[Musique]
est ce que ça existe confondant
ce existe c'est arrivé toi ouais ça
m'est arrivé de tomber amoureux ouais
mais ça
souvent quand je suis avec un garçon
quand j'ai envie de entre guillemets
d'être amoureuse de lui joue un peu la
comédie à moi-même à l'autre à quoi bon
madame on croit qu'on va on croit mais
on y avons c'est à la femme se rend
compte qu'on n'était pas quoi le mot
amour vous ne venez pas tellement
l'employé pourquoi pourquoi parce que
dans les livres dans les films n'importe
où on donne définition de l'amour qu'on
ressent pas je veux dire c'est limite
quelque chose de figé dans la tête des
gens que je sais pas si ça peut être
très violent mais c'est rare on va vous
dire vraiment que ce soit symétrique
parallèle que deux personnes s'aiment
violemment les mots ça c'est très rare
pour moi il ya vraiment de deux choses
qu'il faut bien qu'il faut bien séparer
c'est d'une part les sentiments qu'on
peut avoir envers la personne avec qui
on a une nouvelle relation
la nouvelle personnels qui ont des
relations est bon par exemple le côté ce
que ça peut apporter sur le plan sexuel
et tu sais quoi parce que à mon avis ça
progresse pas au même rythme c'était on
a séparé les deux choses avant l'amour
physique c'était l'amour moral est en
fait il y avait un seul mot pour les
deux maintenant il faudrait réussir à
recréer un deuxième mou c'est à dire un
mot pour l'amour physique et amour pour
la morale on construit nous même quelque
chose on a à construire quelque chose
qu'on sait pas trop comment construire
quand les moeurs évoluent est normal que
le rôle de garçon n'ait pu drive le dry
et maintenant il se fait se fait draguer
et c'est ça qui me gêne en principe
celle qui me plante avant je les ai
planté pendant comment ça se fait ça se
fait que moi je m'attache plus
facilement qu'elle sait pas que
peut-être que j'ai moins besoin de
changement est une question
psychologique
j rien ça regarde personne
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai marché sur une bombe côté ce monde
le plus facile c'est le suicide
et
j'ai marché sur une bombe
[Musique]
m
quoi
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
il
m
comment ça se passe quand vous sortez
avec une fille tellement comment on sort
une film c'est
sort avec une fille vêtue la draille
pendant longtemps tu vas tu vas l'avoir
on importe la méchante lasse pas sérieux
tout sur une fine en forme tout mon
train de danser
c'est sûr que
après il ya celle qu'on
celle qu'on rend compte et puis bon
modèle on la suit pont
on commence à discuter tout et puis à
celle qui viennent spécialement dans les
bals pour avoir une histoire d'un jour à
celles qui cherchent et se dit-on dans
les braves
[Musique]
affaire
si c'est une fille avec qui tu as un
attachement comme ça ça n'empêche pas
d'avoir des histoires à jour ça fait du
bien
là moi je vois pas comme lui bon ben si
j'aurais cru nenê dont j'aimerais pas
que la lunette et là il y avait eu
d'autres mecs je pense que c'est normal
c'est que moi j'avais parlé tout
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais est-ce que tu as bien quand une
fille se refuse quand les tout seul dans
sa ferme ici si elle va raconter aux
copains ouais on perd la face à ces par
rapport aux copains alors là on perd la
face voici frais
sa sirène
[Musique]
m
il le fera
quand vous êtes amoureux qu'est-ce qui
punissent les copains doit avant
peut-être qu'on était jeune quand on
avait 14 ou 15 ans 13 ans que ça
paraissait un peu con froid est à moi
d'utiliser savez maintenant on dit pas
aux copains qu'on est amoureux de la
fille et pourquoi sans l'aperçoit parce
que je suis dans la sas se dit pas
saisis pas parce que on en a honte en
quelque sorte
je suis pas tellement la route mais de
la gêne de dire je suis amoureux d'elle
chez que moi personnellement je fais ici
dit pas encore proche amoureux de
taixing et il est bien là t'es peut-être
plus de chance
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bon le deuxième texte qui vient
maintenant bien sûr qu'en tant que prof
je pense qu'il aurait pu être plus long
mais malgré tout je dirais qu'il
n'exprime pas rien cependant vous allez
voir que votre camarade aurait pu quand
même en mettre plus voilà il a répondu à
cette question dont on avait disputé
qu'est ce que l'amour selon vous je n'en
sais rien j'ai jamais eu l'occasion de
le faire qu'est ce que tu cherches une
relation avec une fille par lexus parce
que je crois que quand on trouve est
arrivé à trouver quelqu'un à qui on peut
avoir des sujets de conversation
vraiment à jeudi qui veut dire qu autre
chose c'est très rare arrivé à contre a
trouvé quelqu'un on va venir les esprits
concordants ça s'est vraiment dit ça me
sert avec la rumeur rarement jusqu'à
présent ob sûr il ya le physique est
tous assez important mais peut-être que
tu cherches dans la relation avec
l'autre attrait pas être juge et surtout
la façon votre vie parce qu'on a
toujours besoin d'être jugé à travers
les autres savaient un petit peu comme
un miroir au fait soi même
pour les loges
[Musique]
ou pas
moi je t'aime signé je t'aime
sinisa voulais me touche tous à la fois
ils sentent one
j'aime seigner hélène antoine tu es
méchant non à doha je t'aime mais ne
faut pas le dire
la fille côté humain digne moi je ne
dors pas je t'aime bien quand même
connard adorable signaux lot
je suis jalouse je t'aime sinistre
icloud stan va finir
qu'est ce qui t'intéresse le plus quand
tu rencontres une fille
[Musique]
je sais pas la conquête la façon la
façon dont type dont on s'y prend le dcc
tout se sait mais je passe ma vie à
faire ça enfin bien sûr on fait là on
parle de ça j'ai fait plusieurs fois
mais monsieur aussi je me suis je le
faisais tout le temps on irait prise
d'intérêt le 10e mois - cherche toujours
le niveau je l'invite lasser qu'est ce
que tu veux te prouver à toi même en
faisant ça mon front et que j'arriverais
donc je suis capable et que j'arriverais
à vouloir plaire à ces personnes non
classés tous vous avez parlé de nette
est bon alors si vous allez voir ce que
vous allez voir on était plus belle
venez sur la danse a fait un jour ça va
non moins de temps de repos mérité
peut-on y voir de plus agréable
tournez-vous un peu s'il vous plaît que
cette taille est jolie aussi un peu la
tête de grandes que ce visage est mignon
ouvrez vos yeux entièrement qui sont
pour que je vois un peu vos dents je
vous primes qu'elles sont amoureuses et
ses lèvres appétissantes pour moi je
suis ravi et je n'ai jamais vu une si
charmante personne
est-ce qu'il arrive par exemple de faire
du charme un garçon qui t'intéresse
rapporte plus que ça juste pour savoir
si ça va marcher
oui très souvent même est en général
souvent le le gars crois que ça va ça va
marcher et puis évidemment moi je veux
pas je veux absolument pas du tout
continuer mais c'est vraiment un jeu
quoi suivant suivant certains garçons
c'est sûr qu'à chaque fois c'est une
certaine facette de moi même c'est c'est
vraiment c'est c'est quelque chose de
très marrant moi je m'amuse énormément
quoi je vais ça et s'il plaît beaucoup
et ils marchent pas
ah bah tant pis j'ai en général je sais
quelque chose même que je préfère un
limites parce que ça c'est quand tu la
maison on apprécie beaucoup plus c'est à
dire ça demande beaucoup plus de travail
entre guillemets dire ça tu veux dire qu
ils aient plus de temps quand il est pas
séduit immédiatement
là je me dis bon il veut pas je te dis
je leur ai amour moi même et en général
ça finit bien donc j'ai jamais eu
non face à risque d'arriver dans ces cas
ça fera peut-être du bir j'en sais rien
en face donc pour l'instant ça toujours
là quel est son élément le plus excitant
de rencontres avec des garçons quel
moment qui te plaît plus
c'est avant c'est c'est c'est en fait
c'est tout ce qui se passe avancer c'est
en fait la parade quoi c'est c'est tout
on le sait chacun qu'on a envie d'être
l'un avec l'autre et puis on honore
notre canton n'est ce pas trop et c'est
ça c'est quelque chose qui m'a toujours
beaucoup beaucoup plus et beaucoup amusé
c'est d'y penser c'est de m'occuper de
vous faire ça lui joue aujourd'hui je
suis bien watts et maïs qu'elle est quoi
l est mais qu'est ce que tu penses tu
que franchement vert
[Musique]
ton chat
c'est une peine que tu vas pas téléphoné
je trouve que ces bananes à des fins
commerciales méconnaît j'adore qu'on
claque ça me donne un sentiment de
supériorité
ça c'est pour le grand don juan des
troisièmes le rapport entre à l'époque
d'avant et c'est maintenant c'est qu'il
ya toujours le même cycle les revoir on
rencontre de toute manière je crois que
je pourrais jamais vraiment longtemps
avec quelqu'un oui parce qu'une relation
enfin à ce moment là on te demanderai
volontiers une relation exclusive et
c'est ce que tu veux un deuxième temps
puis finalement tu es très proche de lui
très proche de donges dont on va bien
mais c'est différent
c'était qu'est-ce qui était différente
chez lui c'était un s'active enfin je
veux dire il est sky et d'avoir gelé moi
je sais pas je ne sais pas d'aveu
d'avoir des femmes comme ça à moi c'est
complètement différent
[Musique]
non
non mr dll pas la musique n'a pas encore
compris les n'aiment pas la musique
salsa fait une heure qu'on bosse agents
démarrent les courbes aux joueurs je
vais rentrer chez eux en plus ma mère
qui gueule en ce moment pourquoi la
gueule de ville a causé samedi à la dure
ouais c'est pas ses tantes atteint non
7h tu pues et en plus non non je n'ai
pas le temps je puis qu'est ce qu'elle a
raconté une meilleure brian m'a dit
qu'ici ces mecs là est tout content on
les a rencontrés en mal escaliers ouais
mais ce qui est séchante aux grasses et
pas seulement qu'elle plus à cause des
photos parce que tu sais que vous
offriez photos etc l achat maman elle
les a dans son sac
et puis de ton âge au fond ça serait ça
serait pratiquement pas normal de ba ne
pas avoir deux garçons ah non ce serait
pas normal maison quand même entre
filles
en fait il ya tout un tout assaut de
mystère qui avait avant bon avant un
baiser sur la bouche et extraordinaire
tandis que maintenant bon nous entre
filles on s'embrasse sur la bouche pour
se dire bonjour
garçons et filles vont régulièrement ce
qu'on appelle des petits pew
on s'embrasse sur la bouche mais tout ça
n'a plus d'importance disons que c'est
en ça où on a envie souvent on a envie
de relations plus profondes pour ça et
encore quelque chose de deux pas banal
ils ont qu'à la limite sortir avec un
mec enfin avec un garçon avec un mec
c'est presque cessé banal enfin c'est
presque évident surtout quand on quand
t'as pas sentiment parce qu'on arrive
très bien sorti avec un garçon sans
sentiments et ça arrive très souvent
quand tu dis sortir avec un trou tu veux
dire par exemple avoir des relations de
leur talent et oui encore quand tu
décrivait cette situation assez grande
liberté
est-ce que ça pose pas de problème vis à
vis des parents s'ils se posent des
problèmes vis-à-vis des parents puisque
bon toute manière les miens sont en plus
tôt contre loeffler puisque ils sont
plutôt pour l'amitié des eaux qui disent
qu entre un garçon et une fille peut
plus y avoir d'amitié puisqu'à partir du
moment où dès qu'on se connaît dès qu'on
se trouve sympa on sent ensemble bon je
pense qu'ils ont pas tort mais ils ont
raison enfin je sais pas à 6 octobre où
ils ont raison mais bon moi je donc
qu'ils aient tort qu'ils aient raison je
suis je vis ce que j'ai envie d'enfin ce
que j'ai lu ce que je sens que j'ai
envie de vivre
bon c'est sûr que je suis obligé de me
cacher ou que je suis obligé de faire
des choses comme ça mais bon j'ai passé
un certain cap maintenant bon ils sont
au courant ils sont pas d'accord je sais
qu'ils sont au courant et je le fais
quand même
agnès
tu as fini
[Musique]
c'est faire des phases ultimes comme ça
on croyait du black and white c'est quoi
le lac à noël [__] ça suffit comme ça
et café à part leurs collègues
en fait j'ai eu une sorte de loi en moi
même je sais que je suis pas assez apt
je suis pas apte à avoir des relations
sexuelles avec un garçon en le vivant
vraiment vraiment quelque chose de
chouette j'ai envie j'ai un idéal j'ai
vraiment envie de vivre quelque chose de
chouette de grande g j'idéalise disons
que j'en ai marre des relations banal on
sort avec un mec parce qu'il faut savoir
on couche avec un mec parce que bon
parce que ça te fait venir une femme ça
on l'a déjà dit parce que tu deviendras
une femme quand tu seras sortir et quand
tu auras coucher avec un garçon moi je
suis pas du tout d'accord disons que je
me sens pas je sais que physiquement et
moralement je serai pas d'apprécier
vraiment cet acte est à partir de ce
moment là bon ben j'ai mieux casser avec
le garçon même si je les adore plutôt
qu'avoir une relation sexuelle avec lui
[Musique]
attendez
avec son coup droit
[Musique]
rien n'allait
j'avais pourtant à jo
enfin
cana semble
[Musique]
toi tu es aussi des parents qui
s'entendent bien ploie oui en plus bon
au bout de je sais pas combien d'années
de mariage prend ça fait vingt-cinq bon
ils s'adorent et ça se voit et bastad
quand même un sacré bel exemple devant
toi est bon ça fait plaisir enfin disons
que à partir de ce moment là on a plus
d' excuse de vraiment faire des grosses
conneries enfin
[Musique]
qui
de rien
[Musique]
à gauche un chaton
car
mais est ce qu'à des moments où tu sens
tu as envie de la deûle à briser cette
règle vendus par là mais bien sûr bien
sûr à tout moment jean vila brisé à
chaque fois j'ai g soit un coût de foot
ou le temps j'ai envie de me dire mais
mr bon allez on oublie tout ça agnès
vas-y laisse toi aller bon mais à chaque
fois bond au dernier moment où ou avant
j'arrive toujours à 10 rebonds non tu
vois et c'est vachement dur c'est sûr
que des fois je me dis bon il faudrait
peut-être réfléchir à deux fois
mais bon je veux le faire et je le ferai
en ce moment je sais pas ce que ça sera
dans trois mois peut-être que dans trois
mois jean a changé je pense pas mais on
sait jamais ça va tellement vite que je
ne sais pas aaaaah algérie une première
leçon non non pas dans une vague dont je
sais que c'est très bon senna trop y
voilà eh oui pour marcel antoine agnès
et les autres que nous allons voir tout
change très vite
à travers le jeu des rencontres on se
cherche on se mesure on se construit
chaque jour un peu plus
et le temps et par la gauche mais pas
d'epo batiscan à leur aise mais ans a
commencé comment pour thouars et les
rassurer que les garçons bizarrement ça
a commencé comme ça commençait dans le
monde où j'étais quand j'avais 12 ou 13
ans tout un peu moins dire que c'était
on se faisait vraiment une gloire
même pas tellement par rapport aux
autres mais par rapport à soi-même
c'était la gloriette de les sur pattes à
la ligue d'une sucette et tout ça deux
de sortir avec un mec est pour toi de
marie comment ça s'est passé
mais moi je crois qu'au départ déjà
j'avais vraiment j'avais une grande
envie de sortir avec un mec mais
pourquoi bon d'avoir effectivement ça
c'est elle et c'était c'est pareil c'est
le côté choix qu'on retrouve tout le
temps de tout est dans la norme
être capable de le faire ça rassure de
ben jawad être normal de simplement
et puis aussi parce que j'avais des
grandes idées sur les sur ce que ce qu
est ce qu on pouvait arriver à faire
quand il y avait une relation amoureuse
avec avec un mec je veux dire j d'alizée
vaches veaux je pensais que ça apportait
des choses fantastiques que fait petit
nuage rose quoi que que l'on voit dans
les filles
moi c'est toi toi c moi non
les réponses
blanche avec une peur ou chapeau
mon chapeau tu sais dans la
[Rires]
mes coordonnées vous
[Musique]
pourquoi ce qu'on décide de sauter le
pas et d'avoir des relations sexuelles
est un garçon c'est une évolution
logique je crois de la chose d'abord je
vois pas comment on pourrait décider
étant donné qu'on n'est pas tout seul
dans affaire il ya deux personnes déjà
en question donc décision vraiment
décision une décision personnelle et
puis nous on décide pas c'est une
évolution logique j'ai quelques soucis
importants plus c'est important plus que
ça va permettre de continuer une
évolution après je crois enfin je crois
je me rendais par le truc de base quand
même s'il faut pas une seule dissimulé
c'est une connaissance déjà du corps de
l'autre savoir comment comme on
appréhende ce genre de contacts très
bientôt relation de contacts ont déjà ça
au départ et comment réagissent les
parents recettes à ce genre de liberté
comprends que vous avez prises à ça
dépend des pats ont déjà fâché pas pour
moi c'est bien quoi sûr puisque ouais ça
s'est vraiment bien passé c'est là que
tu as pu en parler chez toi ouais je
pourrais parler
toute façon ça toujours face à ces une
côte c'est aussi une continuation
logique ça dépend comme la façon dont
étaient élevés mais sont bons ça se
passe chez toi sarko chez toi tu as
toujours plus parler de tout et tu as pu
parler de ça de ça aussi ça aussi mais
pourquoi ces talismans dire extension
est ce qu'il ya un côté blasé qu'on
acquiert très vite quand on voit qu'on a
quand on voit cette liberté que vous
avez pas possible c'est une opinion que
beaucoup d'adultes moment sur fa sur les
sur les relations et des jeunes c'est
que si on commence très tôt à pouvoir
avoir des relations sexuelles très vite
on devient blasé c'est bien parce
qu'elles sont devenues blasé sur leurs
vieux jours parce que justement il avait
pas eu cette liberté en ange pas si à
chaque fois de nouvelles relations de
consciente et ben tu tu veux pas blasé
tu vois bien que c'est pas figé c'est
petit c'est pas toujours la même chose
que c'est quelque chose qui change
énormément tout le temps
[Musique]
emploi
[Rires]
[Musique]
oh
m
[Musique]
couper les fonds
il est
nous avons
non vous ferez rien volé vous ferai rien
à chaque fois c'est pareil vous dites de
m'arrêter puis quand je m'arrête
voulaient pas descendre alors vous
battez comprenez bien que je vais
descendre la grande gueule qui
descendent pas bien grande gueule mais
quand devant gtr des studios de cinéma
qui va descendre sûr qu'il ya des
balisiers ben ali au nom d'al huppert
c'est très bien si je mets toi des
femmes je m'arrêtais et sinon avoir
honte tu toi si tu te sens pas compris
ont désormais leur destin
gueye flipflip besson vas-y vas-y
atteinte à la liberté et il apprend par
rencontre on se connaît
bonjour mademoiselle s qu'ils avaient
leur souplesse 16h55
moi qui sait les killers moissac mois
disent manger moins cinq mois j'ai moins
10 voilà un tomber le par
et que s'il ya dix ans c'est bon et quel
jeu richard bleuettes rencontrer la
coiffure studio vient de lâcher naturel
[Musique]
bien sûr moi je suis un peu gêné parce
que je vous ai toujours dit d'éviter les
mots d'argot où la vulgarité
bon vous allez voir que votre camarade a
cru bon de s'exprimer un moment de cette
façon là bas je pense que s'il l'a fait
c'est qu'ils ne l'avaient les restes des
raisons de le faire hein
l'amour pour moi c'est quelque chose
d'abstrait vu que je n'ai jamais couché
avec une fille toute une nuit bien sûr
m'est arrivé de tremper m'accueille
tirer mon cou en 5 au 10 minutes mais
c'est pas intéressant
il n'ya pas de sentiments entre la fille
et moi mais par contre j'ai eu des
sentiments pour des filles avec qui je
suis sorti sans avoir eu malheureusement
d'actes sexuels
mon problème c'est de réunir les deux
les sentiments et l'amour mais j'ai
beaucoup de problèmes
vu que mon éducation sexuelle je l' ai
fait moi-même pour moi c'est le plus
important les sentiments avec une fille
car ça me fait oublier mes problèmes et
surtout que je suis sur terre de passage
et que je peux très bien crever tout à
l'heure en sortant dans la rue et
morveux le 13 à 15 ans ils vont jamais à
l'école alors toute la journée
sa cavale dans les couloirs
est ce que voulait faire et bilal plus
ball
voilà donc ravi y voient même pas lui
regardez vous même
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas très hospitaliers comme
endroit mais enfin c'est là que les
gosses ils viennent parce que ça leur
plaît parce que des cas qui sont seuls
surtout on les emmerde un petit thé fois
les plus liquides en mer des gardiens
m'enfin c'est pas trop souvent les
descentes alors ça va ils viennent là
puis surtout il ya le chauffage alors il
fait un peu frais je m'appelle chauffage
salle et réchauffe un peu l'hiver puis
quelqu'un construit avec laquelle jouent
toute façon une grande maison de jeunes
y apprend de terrain il n'y a rien de
façon je pense aller vite parce que dans
les cas d'acquittement dire c'est la
faute des parents et tout mais enfin je
tiens les cheerios à 4h30 pour en sortir
c'est pas la peine d'avoir 14 ans
justement d'être jeune historien est
ouvert les départs et 6 jours montre
autre chose
alors là ils ont cassé la porte
et puis ils sont 160 installé voyez là
ils ont commencé à y déployer tous à la
lépi dont milan petite lampe d'affiche
bis av rien en faire leur saloperie avec
leur fille vous pouvez leur dire
alors moi je veux que vous êtes toujours
entre garçons là je suis venu quand un
garçon
[Musique]
toujours là et là encore vous n'êtes pas
là qu'est ce que vous faites vous n'êtes
pas ici avant les meubles la route ont
fait défaut vous devriez être à l'école
à votre âge donc qu'est ce qui vous
arrive d'aller à l'école
lui aussi s'est pas non plus moi je sais
que tu vas pas dit comment il faut
savoir qu'avant je profite évidemment
pas la route
mais quel choix aléatoire et comme a dit
l'un et tes parents qu'est ce qu'ils
font dans la vie des parents
qu'est-ce qui fait on perd je vois je
n'ai gardé que des bons rapports avec
elles avec eux avec les roms c'est sympa
avec tomboy
j'ai tout le temps bof un beau trou là
bonjour tu te laisses tu sais pas
[Rires]
[Musique]
quand vous passez votre journée je crois
en moi je sais pas on discute donc quand
vous discutez qu'est ce qui vous
intéresse dans la vie quand vous passez
votre temps on sent
soit on va chez chery camarades ou des
trucs de la musique et quand tu es avec
tes copains là en bas vous avez toute la
dette entre garçons originaires
vous n'êtes pas tellement avec des
filles n'ont pas tellement savez pour
une fois ce n'est avec des filles temps
ouais ça arrive ouais est ce qu est ce
qu est ce que tu plais the von teese est
pas franchement qu'est ce que tu veux
comme une fille te plaît quand il aborde
un arrêt comment comment tu dit prêt à
discuter avec elles voient ça j'aurais
faut voir ça
non tu pas me raconter comment tu sais
du nord bon alors on passe à autre chose
et est ce que tu as des relations dans
sa patrie avec des parents et des
familles ils sont sympas tes parents et
qu'est-ce que tu arrives de discuter
avec avec eux deux
des filles déjà en tournage est ce que
vous faites n'ont jamais beaucoup au
pourquoi ça n'intéresse pas non c'est
parce que c'est leur intérêt soit mais
je peux en vue de discuter c'est ta vie
privée ou c'est parce que il en parle
tout le temps non wes m'avait privé
qu'est ce qu'il fait on perd la vie et
on avait vite été trahie par l'homme et
toi ce que tu avais tu as déjà travaillé
non j'avais cette envie de travailler
ouais je cherche juste travailler en ce
moment et qu'est-ce que tu devrais faire
je crois nous apporte quoi du moins j'ai
hâte de l'argent tu as besoin d'argent
ouais pour faire quoi en quoi cette
manque l'argent ça vous regarde et
comment est-ce que comment est ce que tu
vois l'avenir ton avenir à toi chevaux
j'avais beau monde à venir et un fichier
ces choses là tu es jeune tu as déjà
essayé d'imaginer comment sa lettre je
vais pourquoi ça vous intéresse porc
cuit au jour le jour pour l'instant
est ce que tu as des projets
j'enlève au projet n'ont même pour
demain pour après-demain pour moi
j'arrive au bouquin
je veux tu es un peu sur tes relations
avec des filles quand tu quand tu sors
avec des ficelles arrive quand même
ouais ça me regarde mais là je pose pas
de questions indiscrètes pour l'instant
je pose des questions les filles avec
qui tu sors c'est des filles de la cité
où ce défi d'ailleurs ça dépend
d'ailleurs quand on sait comment ils
sont sept de la cité elles sont
sympathiques et tu discutes un peu avec
moi je souhaite
comment elles sont deux filles de son
âge que moi je les trouve plus je trouve
ces coupes
voilà presque photo respect du droit un
jour vivre en couple marié ou pas mais à
tanger avait pour nom ça représente quoi
pour toi le lit des deux couples la
stabilité de la fin enfin la fin ouais
[Musique]
aussi dominique est un enfant de la cité
ouais je cite je suis arrivé ici à
quatre ans vingt deux ans que j'habite
comme ça de près la même expérience que
les jeunes avec lesquels on vient de
discuter je suis le problème chose qu'il
faut accueillir moment oui parce que
beaucoup de nos questions sont restées
avec eux sa réponse est tellement de
choses qu'on ne peut pas dire c'est pas
que ces choses ne peut pas dire c'est
que c'est un peu normal qu'il ne puisse
pas le dire pour gagner parce que ils
sont pas encore arrivés à y réfléchir on
bat en tant qu'éco celui-ci d'amener
jamie lee pas amené à lire on défonce
avec les potes on fait des conneries
fédéral terrain mais n'ont jamais abouti
né à essayer de réfléchir sur soi même
réfléchir sur de ce qui se passe autour
voit son petit monde sa petite cité ses
petits copains inquiète tous moi j'ai
fait des conneries
j'étais puni pour ça et puis quel genre
de paris qui faisait alors j'ai commencé
comme par des vols dans les caves comme
tout le monde et puis des cons village
les pavillons de commerçants et terrain
ça m'aide à me faire arrêter et puis un
autre homme en prison
houssin un peu partout qu'est-ce qui est
qu'est ce que tu as fait en prison
bah rien fait je bouquine est bon pour
moi ça s'est passé un moment où j'avais
besoin de deux solitudes de réfléchir de
d'autres shows de connaître d'autres
gens de fin d' arrêter surtout des
contacts avec des voleurs étaient
terrain mais nous avons des gars ça
s'est mal passé d'être seul en cellule
pour un type quand un type idées au
boudin à bout d'un mois on était tout
seul en cellule
pourquoi demander moindre accès 1 et
quelqu'un s'il ya du verre qui cependant
puisque les veines qui se passait pas sa
marque par les journaux enfin toutes et
tous les jours toujours ça arrive moi je
lui dis je pense être un car je suis
encore je suis un cas je crois bien
surtout j'ai changé profondément quand
quand une femme est attendue tard une
femme qui m'a attendu un an
et puis julien enfants avec alors ça
donne à réfléchir aussi ça ça m'a amené
à me dire que j'ai pas tout seul quoi
et l'avenir de nos enfants qu'ils
pensaient ouais je pense avec des
demanderesses pas ici aussi parce que
s'ils sont terribles il se passe ici du
bien peur qu'ils veulent la même chose
que moi et puis je voulais pas du
collège monique moi c'est ça justement
les jeunes de la cité ici on a
l'impression que j'ai des rapports assez
pauvre intelligent n'a même le relation
qu'ils ont des difficultés à entrer en
relation avec des filles dans les wild
en difficulté avant on l'a donc des
filles parce que les filles se méfie
d'eux déjà juste mes fils et filles un
ton avis et a des conséquences
bah oui c'est un des consultants parce
que si si j'avais plus de rapport avec
des filles il y aura plus qu enfin il y
aurait plus confiance en eux mêmes déjà
ça ferait ça ferait il serait moins seul
et puis j'aurais pu être plus
convaincant mais même alors il cherchera
peut-être autre chose à faire mais
grégory quand j'étais plus jeune j'avais
beaucoup de complexes jour j'ai possédé
une femme tous mes complexes sont
effacés ça a joué si on en a envie
d'enrichir mon esprit je n'arrivais pas
à comprendre comment une femme avait pu
s'intéresser à moi
ce jour là je croyais être devenu un
homme mais je compris bien vite que
c'était une illusion
maintenant pour moi être un homme c'est
respecter les êtres qui m'entourent
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
oh pardon je suis vraiment désolé
infirme seulement une jambe dans le
plâtre firmes comme vous à gérer
vous vous intéressez à la en 1900 je
sais pas j'y connais pas grand chose
mais je suis ça c'est joli c'est joli 1
femme nue et or on n'avait jamais vu ça
dans paris bah ça ressemble un peu au
musée de la ged affiche vous allez
souvent au musée de la fiche moi je vais
très souvent obligés d'afficher j'ai
l'impression d'avoir déjà vu quelque
part c'est sûrement aux visées de la
fille mais c'est pas du tout d'ailleurs
nous aborder je vous jure je vous ai vu
quelque part
ah si si j'en suis certain écoutez il ya
une fille musée de la fiche qu'elle est
cheveux plus longs que vous vous êtes
vous avez coupé travailler parmi les
affiches absolument pas non elle a à peu
près les mêmes je vous l a à peu près
les mêmes couleurs et
brille aussi un peu comme ça comme ça
vous vous intéressez un peu leurs 19 100
musées d'affiché que vous avez pas froid
là et a particulièrement parce que moi
je meurs de france j'irais bien boire un
café ou voulait pas venir relativement
non voir un café vous alliez par là et
comme le café plus près qu'il a que je
suis là là bas je préfère aller par là
bas avec dernier c'est pas vraiment le
temps parce que je suis toujours allé
sami luxe en bois un petit café on
discute un peu comme un garçon de fait
la cour comment tu reçois ça eh ben ça
dépend si pendant général je suis plutôt
accueillante toi je suis pas du genre à
lever la tête
comment je dire dans la rue si quelqu'un
me dit bonjour d'une façon ça bâtit je
réponds ce qui en général est beaucoup
les jours d'ailleurs
et puis sinon et si le type est
sympathique et que je suis branché
ben je serai très accueillants que si
jamais ils chient mange pas vraiment un
peu moins accueillante
c'est à dire que je serai gentil mais
relativement froides de façon à faire
groupe enfin je sais pas je ne sais pas
comment je me rends compte des salles
des très bien face est assez clair en
général pour ce que tu engages des
rapports avec des garçons qu'est ce que
tu recherches
quand tu quand tu as en face d'un garçon
d'abord d'abord un peu du rêve quand
même quand même un peu de rêve ça j'aime
bien un peu les romans d'amour etc etc
et puis en général quelqu'un de pas trop
enfin cette saisie très sectaire ce que
je vais dire mais relativement
intéressant c'est super franchement ça
super bien
t'as pas d'une exposition qui avait eu
autant d'écho s'intéresse à la musique
un peu oui oui ça dépend des musiques
disco n'ayant pas le discours
ça tombe bien moi non plus la musique
brésilienne
ah oui en plus ça va être long meilleur
déjà que vaut sa d'horreur à voyait
vraiment même dur un instrument piano je
suis la bossa nova au piano voilà un
terrain d'entente
c'est pas mal alors chez moi il ya un
piano une guitare un ampli un
magnétophone et du chocolat et des
petits gâteaux ronds et l du thé et ma
mère je alors qu'un esprit qui
m'intéresse il faut que je trouve
intéressante à rien puisqu'il tourne
intéressante
ceci je sens que je passe pour une conne
et là c'est terminé bonsoir oui alors là
ce que tu ce que tu t'y penses à se
passe au niveau de bon de la rencontre
comme ça ben ouais mais au niveau moral
qu'est-ce que tu demande une certaine
d'abord à une certaine compréhension
entre les deux la tendresse pour j'aime
bien être mauvaise et puis la
gentillesse aussi je sais pas comment le
moral en plus papa sentir tout seul ce
qui serait - ce qui est extrêmement
désagréable qu'on est des fois avec des
gens c'est que c'est des fois on arrive
à trouver des gens ou avec a vécu on
sent encore plus seul que d'habitude
là ça que ça marche pas
des banques c'est toujours possible là
je deviens 100 est de savoir si on
cherche un goût on va dire coup comme ça
beaucoup mais on installe
voilà et puis voilà un guichet où jean
mariage est carrément 6 3
[Rires]
est ce que toi tu vas tu as envie
d'avoir une famille plus tard ah ouais
vraiment ah ouais vraiment même des plus
en plus quoi mais moi je ne m'en suis
pas marié demain matin vraiment j'ai
envie d'avoir un mari elle marie pour
qui j'avais de l'admiration qui sera
gentil d'avoir des bébés tuant 2 4 ou 5
si j'ai des sous deux filles et deux
garçons
voilà et puis je vais avoir une famille
très bien et puis si je pouvais faire
une famille aussi bien que mes parents
ont fait une famille je serais vraiment
contente quoi parlement un peu plus de
ton futur mari par exemple est ce que tu
pourrais avoir un métier qui soit
supérieur au sien ou non ça m'embêterait
un peu c'est d'être à préconçue mais en
fait je crois que j'aurais du mal à
vivre quelqu'un ou même à aimer
quelqu'un je me sentirai supérieur à lui
quoi j'ai vraiment besoin d'avoir un peu
de l'admiration pour la personne d'en
face et pour avoir un prêt d'admiration
faut que je me suis un petit peu plus
pas la femme soumise mais un petit peu
de ça quand même
mais qu'est ce que tu veux faire tout à
ton avis
je reste commissaire de police alors
c'est drôle en général les gens rigolent
très fort
m
et
car avant de casser la gueule
ça fait
m
apparemment tu es très heureuse oui même
faute à terre d'avoir un grand équilibre
enfin tué apparemment ouverte et en même
temps heureusement on peut dire ouais je
crois enfin j'ai changé première place
est ce que tu sais à quoi ça tient ça
que je sois que je fais est équilibrée
et ce en quoi je crois que ça tient
beaucoup à ma famille et à mon avis à
mon éducation en général parce que ma
famille est équilibré déjà qu est ce que
tu entends par équilibré on ne va pas y
être maman tu as un métier intéressant
ils ont toujours des choses
intéressantes à dire et ils s'aiment
beaucoup ce qui est quand même basique
et le reste de la famille s'aiment
beaucoup et puis et puis en plus bonne
planification peut-être un peu
religieuse quoi qui fait qu' ils ont
toujours été très accueillants et très
ouvert avec les gens et c'est à mes
frères et soeurs aussi et je crois que
ça joue beaucoup quoi la religion quand
je pense que les joueurs oui beaucoup
oui beaucoup tué de quelle confession
catholique
tu vas la main ce we à l'essai je suis
partie de la chorale une autre
oh
alors
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
ce que je trouvais bien en fait avancé
qu' il y avait d'abord l'amour moral
enfin c'était il va y avait l'amour
moral et puis l'amour moral était été
concrétisée par l'amour physique et puis
est alors pour arriver au summum
non seulement il y avait l'amour moral
et y avait l'amour physique et puis en
plus y avait le plaisir quoi et 7 ça
concrétise est complètement tout est en
plus alors avec ce plaisir on n'a rien
on faisait ancré à droite et m quoi
c'est à dire non c'est un enfant je
trouve ça très bien quoi ce sens que
c'est vraiment le summum de
l'explication de l'amour qu'il peut y
avoir
alors maintenant vont évidemment le
problème c'est que le plaisir a pris un
peu du pas sur le reste et c'est un peu
normal et et je critique personne parce
que je suis absolument comme tout le
monde aimait à mon avis c'est un peu
dommage
tu ressembler un peu à cette terre
d'avant onkalo paix les chevaux tout
blanc ton regard était faire et tout
sourire clair j'ai marché tout droit des
états lumière si je comprends bien en ce
qui concerne les relations avec des
garçons qui n'a pas une position trop
définit non non mais bien sûr en fait
j'étais aux riches heures je suis obligé
de suivre le mouvement je veux dire
parce que à la limite j'ai beau jean
raimbault à très amoureuse je veux dire
arriver à mon âge si je disais bon ok
mais mariage quoi chanter moi un énorme
éclat de rire devant moi et puis ça
serait terminée quoi et puis en fait
au fond de moi j'en ai un peu envie
aussi je veux dire je suis comme tout le
monde je suis pas vraiment je suis pas
vraiment content parce que je suis comme
ça et que et il s'est agi sur moi aussi
mais je crois que dans le fond c'est une
ode à mon tort c'est toi qui as tort oui
c'est mon cutter
[Musique]
oh
une femme
avec toi
à
[Musique]
m
le
à une femme
dans les bras
le
est ce à moi avec le jeune fille que ce
discours s'adresse non à personne bon
ben on a refait notre foi
[Musique]
mais ce qui est drôle c'est que tu es
cette position en faut qu'ils aient
trait apparemment très équilibré mais
qu'en même temps tu la critique afin que
tu n'assumes pas complètement et que tu
ne peux tu dis ce que je suis un peu
perdue alors en fait sur ce plan là ça
peu près le seul plan ou je sais pas
trop comment penser est-ce que tu as
confiance dans l'avenir
moi j'ai très confiance je crois que
tout va très bien s'arranger au fait tu
es et ce que tu as confiance aussi dans
conte à venir de coucou de mariage ouais
c'est aussi assez aussi parce que parce
que moi je suis décidé à ce que ça
marche bien et je crois qu'en général
les gens pareils les gens de mon âge
sont à ces six jeunes 68 était très très
pour tout faire exploser en je crois que
les gens ici et maintenant son taux
relativement terre à terre est très
sensée et enfin en gros ils ont tous
envie de faire une famille de vivre
heureux en fait normalement mais heureux
quoi génération c'est ça on est marron
et pour toujours basse et pour toujours
tu n'es tu pas comment j'y reviendrai
pirée tout bas ça ça change bien on est
marrant ça suffit pour que ça change ou
bien on est marron
non pas que tu as payé pour faire du blé
si tu comptes amusé mon post était musée
s'est produit jeudi c'est la terrible
acte et enfants puissent en profiter ça
suffit il faut que ça change bien on est
marron ça suffit pour que ça change eh
bien les marrons
[Musique]
tel que ton histoire tu vas en barétous
finir accrocha tu vas papa maman fait tu
avais tu seras ce projet vu que les
horribles et ça suffit ça change ou bien
au 10 mars
[Musique]
non
ça c'est une place en ligue 1
oh ça c'est fini pour la change bien les
mains ça suffit de potash corp
[Musique]
est ce que c'est bien qu'on parle un
poste est relâché avec des filles ouais
moi personnellement ça me dérange pas
est-ce que tu as du succès de leurs
grands espaces avec les
ce que tu racontes je me débrouille toi
en plus ce n'est pas plus pas moins
qu'un autre je suis dans les temps ou
est-ce que tu des rencontres annuelles
main n'importe où peut être dans la rue
dans le métro
n'importe où comment tu t'organises pour
les aborder de prendre quel sens ça
c'est vachement brian général autres qui
attaque bien c'est yahia et un tilt
chaque côté qu'ils ont fait et c'est
réciproque en principe si après la
réciprocité ce programme
quand tu sors avec une fille alors
qu'est ce que vous faites ensemble vous
c'est pas votre emploi du temps tu vas
au cinéma tu vas au bistrot non
on va on va de soi chez moi on va chez
eux on se balade
pourquoi tu
vous n'allez pas de les balancer des
trucs comme ça alors pourquoi ça se fait
par des tapas ou pas d'argent qu'est ce
que c'est important en plus je suis bien
que je suis bien quand je suis avec elle
quoi et c'est réciproque en principe
s'isoler un peu quoi vous y allez ouais
tu t'isoles de quelle façon je parle moi
quand je suis avec elle tu vois je pense
à elle pense à moi tout ça on se fait un
petit univers quoi fait commun comme une
bulle autour de nous comme une aura une
bulle mais qu'est ce qu'il ya en dehors
de cette bulle
j'invite le reste c'est quoi ne cessent
ces gens c'est le monde c'est le monde
extérieur c on est bien derrière la
bulle
wall stret on y est mieux sinon c'est
servir à rien je suis pas maso j'ai
manqué ce que tu cherches tellement 1 à
fuir qu'est ce que tu veux quitter quand
tu te mets à toutes les contraintes
qu'on a ne je sais pas comment dire et
genre de contraintes tués
je passe je suis jeune et je suis né
dans mes mouvements j'ai l'impression
d'être enchaîné venir les gens j'ai
l'impression qu'on cherche toujours à me
coincer qu'on cherche toujours à nous
qu'est ce qu'ils cherchaient de coincer
je parlerai str c'est l'impression que
le monde et 6,6 violence ici au passif
que ça ah ouais chez on m'a fait une
impression permanente je suis gêné mais
alors est ce que tu crois qu'on est
jeune et plus pressé quand on attendra
je suis content et de l'adulte ou bien
tu as well non non c'est pas pareil donc
mon mât quand on est à mon âge on a
envie de bouger on a envie de mon envie
de vivre quoi comme quand on est adulte
bon ben on est rangé des voitures que
tardif
ah ouais ça il n'y a pas de problème je
sais parfaitement
[Musique]
le monde ya plus de jeunesse gps
immortalité
on peut répéter
parce que qu'est ce qui te plaît là on
en fait d'avoir un gros que ça l'amusé
le disons que ça me manque déjà
ça me permet de crier au monde ce qu'est
ce ce que j'ai en moi qu est-ce que ce
que des fonds soient
c'est ce que j'ai sur le coeur quoi ça
parce je leur jette gillot balance
je vous ai écrit des chansons way
quand tu repensera moi je serai bien un
déjà je serai dans tes souvenirs
tu dragues impression de plaisir
passe-passe nos sentiments c'est pas ce
point de presse
l'avenir nous n'est pas un passe temps
l'histoire expérience fini tu te
réveilles tu te retrouves dans ton lit
cauchemar où les invités qui poursuivent
leur course effrénée
ban ques peine cachée de la lune pas tu
as dû arriver que tu piloter un avion
comme ça ah oui puisque je voulais être
pilote de ligne de toute façon je serai
pas pilote de ligne alors j'attends je
fais rentrer dans l'industrie - toute
façon je vais tâcher d'obtenir plus de
qualification possible
la force du pays est ton avenir avec les
filles est ce que tu le vois aussi je
crois que bon ben on tout homme est né
pour fonder un foyer à mon avis alors
toute façon je n'échapperai pas à la
règle mais j'ai pas du tout envie
d'échapper à la règle mon avenir avec
les fismois c2c de faire une famille
quoi on est une famille appelée heureuse
possible avec des enfants aussi mais
avec des enfants lafonta des projets
assez précis c'est précis sur le plan
sur le plan familial sur tous les plans
puisque tu sais tu connais ton métier tu
connais ta femme et fasse que tuera pour
le reste je fais pas de projets quand on
fait pas de projet serait vite souvent
d'être déçus l'amour pour moi c'est
avoir une femme ailée mais quand on aime
quelqu'un on oublie les soucis de la vie
l'amour c'est aussi avoir des enfants
pour continuer le cycle de la vie
l'amour c'est s'aider dans la vie quand
il ya des moments difficiles
l'amour peut également exister en dehors
du besoin physique pour le réconfort du
couple il ça correspond à quoi devions
être quelqu'un on sait qu enfin il ya
plein c'est même en fait quand on s'en
rend compte parce qu'il ya plein de
choses qu'on
bon quand on aime on n'imagine même pas
que ça puisse être difficiles et on
s'aperçoit par exemple c'est pas moi de
de manger avec quelqu'un je sais pas de
faire des petits trucs bête quoi de tous
les jours bon bah ça on se rend compte
que c'est difficile petit à petit en
fait alors qu'on a l'impression que ce
qu'est le plus difficile c'est à des
grandes les grandes la passion et c'est
en fait le choix vraiment c'est plus
difficile de mener une vie quotidienne à
la limite c'est plus facile bon d'être
allé voir un mec que tous les soirs je
dis ça d'aller voir un mec tous les
soirs et de bombes sortir avec le
coucher avec selon le cas que de que
d'avoir vraiment à comprendre les
différences de vue qu'on a sur la vie et
commence à puce se goupiller pour que sa
note bon la première étape c'est de se
rendre compte que pour vivre avec
quelqu'un il faut faire des concessions
c'est évident une fois qu'on y
réfléchisse et puis ensuite ce qui est
pas évident c'est d'être capable de les
faire ces concessions quand on se rend
compte qu'on est capable on se dit qu'on
va pouvoir tirer profit de la vie qu'on
mènera comme ça et ça fait toujours
plaisir c'est sûr mais est-ce que c'est
pas là est-ce que c'est pas la perte des
illusions sa fille tout cas si c'est une
perte de lisieux c'est pas trop
douloureux parce que c'est quand même
mieux penser c'est mieux c'est mieux que
le stade précédent qui est
qui est justement très individualiste et
pas c'est curieux de voir que vous dites
ça alors qu'au fond vous êtes vous êtes
quand même très jeune vous avez quel âge
bientôt 17 n'ont donc maintenant vous
vous sentez prête à vivre avec avec un
garçon tout cas enfin pas mal envie
prête je sais pas c'est quoi
bah non je n'avais pas de boîte étanche
à l'eau froide témoins pour nous c'est
parce qu'on pourra espérer beaucoup de
kilos de vote de kilos de vodka 3 litres
de jus d'orange à son nom pour faire une
salade de fruits des fruits
les oranges des pommes des bananes des
noix tout celle dont il savait
désabonnement des pommes
[Rires]
oui à la paix à ton goût vraiment
performant sur l'oder matin
à notre peau c'est tout voilà justement
je vais devoir alors petit moineau
qu'est ce qui s'est passé au cours de
son temps que tu n'étais pas là non je
dis pas je suis allé chez le médecin de
jemal avait quelque chose qui va pas
grave
petit ennui c'est pas grave mais mon
fallait que j'y aille au bout et
j'espère que ça ira mieux mais
affrontements un mot d'accord est tout
petit le fur qu'est ce qui s'est passé
vendredi dernier entre 4 et 5
vendredi dernier c'était un cours de
russe et sur wii il était supprimée
parce que c'était une heure que la prof
de russe devait récupérer la prof
d'histoire qu'il avait
emprunter à 10 % avant tu trouves passe
un peu envoyez non pas du tout c'était
simple et vraiment une sale gamine bon
écoutez vous êtes de bonne élève mais ça
ne suffit pas le règlement c'est pour
tout le monde bon allez filet je vois
pas comment on peut concilier la vie
avec quelqu'un et le leak c'est parce
que j'ai d'ailleurs ça m'entraîne à me
poser des questions sur le comment on
peut concilier vivre avec quelqu'un et
travailler même à la limite quoi et je
me rends compte que là encore il va
falloir faire des concessions par
rapport aux envies qu'on a ou
oui c'est sûr explique moi un peu
pourquoi c'est contradictoire au fond la
vie avec quelqu'un et le lycée unis
c'est parce que la vie avec quelqu'un
c'est quelque chose qui va t'amener à
prendre des responsabilités ce qu'on
appelle ici jusqu'à présent donc tu ne
penses tu vas devoir assumer quelque
chose et au lycée entre les rôtir
soigneusement correspond servir quelque
chose toi même le givre est encore sur
les voitures
le pas nonchalant mes voisins dorment
encore
seuls les poubelles de la rue semble
vide
mes yeux se rivent sur l'ancienne maison
de ma grand mère j'ai passé là mon
enfance
la belle époque maintenant je deviens
adultes je prends mes responsabilités
boulevard de la marne d'après mes
habitudes je devrais être olp dans 20
minutes
quel calvaire 20 minutes quand je pense
à certains profs tard et qui les génère
qu'elle mongol au croisement une fille
matin l'enviro 18 ans habillée d'une
veste de peau sa longue chevelure rousse
lui tombant sur les épaules elle vient
vers moi elle m'embrasse d'un baiser
affectueux puis je repars à main droite
sur son épaule sa main gauche à ma
taille
mon seul plaisir de la journée tout en
marchant je parle de mes cours à
geneviève elle répond hochant la tête et
c'est la règle du 110m jeu lembras et
lui fixe un rendez vous à la sortie des
cours
elle monte dans le disent elle
s'installe me fait un dernier signe de
tête et les puces de marc
[Applaudissements]
je repars en parlant entre mes dents je
repense au bout du chemin que j'ai fait
avec geneviève à cette fille pleine de
douceur et de joie de vivre
elle est vraiment bien je me remets à
marcher d'un pas lourd
j'entame une chanson à ma façon ah ça
ira ça ira les professeurs ou les pendra
a je pense qu'on les regrettera ses
chèvres ânes bâtés
ils nous font travailler mais on les
aime bien j'arrive au lep plein de
soucis
mécontent de cette saloperie de journée
maintenant je pense à ce que je pourrais
faire ce soir avec geneviève à quelle
misère
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
oh
non
[Musique]
si je comprends bien ce moment tu es
plutôt solitaire n'a pas de petite amie
attitrée banon hop west
voilà geneviève la jeune fille dont tu
parles dans sa rédaction
oui c'était il ya longtemps ça remonte à
peu près un an
oui mais semble que tu as laissé un très
fort souvenir
ah oui c'était une fille vraiment on
peut lire dans adorable trois semaines
non non c'est pas beaucoup mais vraiment
appris beaucoup de choses avec mc je
suis disons elle m'a beaucoup marqué
parce que avec elle j'ai sorti du stade
enfants hossa d'adolescence il fait
passer une frontière
il m'a appris beaucoup de choses
et pourquoi vous tu n'es plus avec elle
pourquoi elle s'est arrêtée à trouver
une autre
non non non mais s'arrêter comme ça on
en avait peut-être assez de l'autre il
avait suffisamment appris vous savez qu
est ce que tu penses des défis
aujourd'hui jusque là une certaine
liberté qui est bien que les défis sont
prix libre qu'avant parce que qu'est-ce
que tu penses de cet hiver terrifie un
général mais il a un côté ça m'arrange
bien sûr je peux pas nier mais d'un
autre côté c
c'est gênant ça change beaucoup
ça change trop vite c'est donc ça va
trop vite tout ça on perd la tête donc
cette évolution cette instabilité tu ça
te dérange quelque part oui ça c'est ça
dérange beaucoup plus comme avant qua
non avant les c'était toujours les mecs
qui faisait le premier par maintenance
et c'est les filles vraiment plaisir on
tête baissée ça dérange plus faut s'y
habituer toi ouais c'est pas tout à fait
encore habitués n'ont pas tu as fait est
ce qu'une époque dans l'histoire où tu
te serais bien aimé vivre plutôt que
plutôt qu'un autre
ah oui c'est au temps des chevaliers ça
peut être bizarre mais j'aime
il est temps des chevaliers parce que
dans ce temps là il y avait l'autorité
il y avait le nord c'était ça marche
impeccable mais toi est-ce que tu ne
crois pas qu'aujourd'hui il faut
interpréter de l'ordre et l'autorité de
façon différente
pourquoi les hommes de tous horizons
fait pour sont faits pour pour exécuter
les ordres ont salué comme ça est-ce que
tu tiens le terrain capable toi de les
écouter des ordres quelles que soient
les ordres ben oui quoi c'est semble
impossible
papa qui à un moment ont fléchi à la
nature des heures alors qu on est en
train d'en savoir écouter quand on
réfléchit trop n'arrivait une conclusion
que bombana côté on fait on n'a pas
d'ennui et l'autre on le fait pas et on
a beaucoup d'ennuis en vaut mieux foncer
tête baissée puis on verra ce qui est de
façon j'aime leur j'aime pas les choses
qui vont de travers je me soit
impeccable
est ce qui te plaît pas dans les
relations avec les filles
en ce moment c'est que c'est un petit
peu n'importe quoi peu pressé
si maintenant on prend une fille bon ma
peau ici pour s'amuser pour la rejette
cinq minutes après c'est dommage
avant c'était pas tout à fait ça il y
avait autre chose avant qu'est ce que ça
veut dire avoir
est ce qu'aujourd'hui dans la liberté
des relations entre les garçons et les
filles on ne peut pas aussi trouver
autre chose
ans
[Musique]
oh
oui
[Musique]
oh
elle
faux
[Musique]
celui qui va voir
depuis
cinq mois qu'est ce qui te plaît j'ai
dit et ce qui fait que tu as envie de te
déplacer j'ai l'impression de
je veux plus fort avec lui qu'avec les
autres qu'est ce qui a changé justement
par rapport à des aventures précédentes
vcli
de quelle façon s'est creusé
s'est creusé
mon amour
au niveau des relations physiques
s'assure que
enfin non pas en avant
et puis
il ya quelques choses vachement
important qui s'est inséré c'est la
tendresse on fait vivre
et ça ça correspond à une évolution
auxerre j'ai vachement senti voitures et
des relations sexuelles sans tendresse
amant
c'est en dépossédant porte au nez
sans tendresse dans le sens où t'as pas
tellement tente occupée de l'autre parce
que tu as tellement à découvrir à tous
de découvrir toi découvrir la ligue les
capacités de ton corps enfin tout ce que
tu veux
en fait tu t'occupes pas de l'autre
c'est vachement plus c'est vachement
plus égoïste
kotido
cette fois c'est celui que tu invites
descoings
oui
qu'est ce que tu veux digérer ce dément
que tu t'engages plus
ben oui c'est sûr je m'engage plus
peut-être aussi parce que je ressens
plus cette phase hic
une fois précédent
ce n'est pas le danger justement chez
moi
à donner à l'autre
ainsi parce que tu donnes tu donnes
d'abord
moi je sais pas j'ai pas envie de me
donner ou
je veux garder quelque chose pour moi
aussi et puis c'est sûr que bon tu
donnes tu sais pas ça le plaisir retenue
ça fait plaisir de donner c'est sûr mais
quand tu sais que ça va être reçue et le
danger c'est qu'un jour ça soit plus
reçue est là
c'est sûr que ça doit être tu pense
souvent que ça peut s'arrêter
on essaye c'est évident
lui vit là bas at on dit à paris est ce
que tu penses à ce qui fait qu'on n'est
pas là
jalousement allemands y penser c'est sûr
je veux dire dans le sens où je pense à
lui je pense tient jalousement dans
l'est qu'est ce que tu fais tu
du quai un carreau
voilà où il arrive de tomber on paie ça
peut pas être trompée de cette façon il
ne sait toujours sincères et le lit
c'était quelque chose de pause au départ
m pour moi c'est essentiel
c'est essentiel d'avoir la possibilité
d'aller chercher d'aller voir ce qui se
passe ailleurs n'avoir d'autres
ouvertures
de voir deux ans de relation il accepte
facilement mais
d'abord c'est l'étonnement c'est pas de
courant je veux dire ça marche souvent
dans le sens le mec est une ana en fait
c'est très rare que les
que les nanas
réclame 1
l'égalité
dans une caisse cabine
il a compris quand même
de toute façon je pense que quelque
chose d'irremplaçable dans les relations
qu'on peut avoir longtemps
enfin des relations qui durent c'est
justement la durée parce que ça ça amène
des contacts complètement différent et
en général les relations que j'ai en
dehors de cette relation durable c'est à
dire vraiment pas longtemps
peut-on un soir où de soi un truc comme
ça mais là par exemple dont on peut
imaginer que c'est en intensité c'est
plus fort c'est vraiment différent c'est
souveraine à niveau tout à fait
différent est ce qu'il ya des moments où
j'ai trouvé cette liberté est lourde à
porter est ce que tu t'es affectivement
bas sentiment de vertige
on c'est sûr que si c'est pas évident
c'est pas du tout évident de
de sentir que
en fait la personne pour pour résoudre
les problèmes à ta place que tu vas
devoir tu vas devoir l'aider à fond
magnet plusieurs fois ou
j'avais vraiment envie et ça me faisait
un peu penser à redevenir un petit
moment pour être complètement prise en
charge et ussel mais en fait je sentais
que ça m'apporte est trop belle
tu es pour que ce jeu
je sais dès que je me lève prendre en
charge au fait tu veux pas rire avec
avec une morale toute cette eau
j'ai l'impression que ça doit être
quelque chose de personnel
et c'est tellement impersonnel justement
c'est
ce conte
ça a été créé je sais pas trop comment
la morale c'est que je ne
personnel
ça dépend de chaque individu
c'est ça le sens de la vie d'une maison
commune c'est la même
s
qu'est-ce qu'on ressemble à franchir des
étapes comme ça
je n'ai pas ensemble on est en train d'y
penser
notre expérience qui est pas celle des
autres qui la montrent qu'à chaque fois
que j'attaque et en général ça se
traduit par des moments difficiles à
passer quoi nous faut que tu les as
passé et tu sens que ça t'a apporté
quelque chose avec ça pas au rand ce
qu'il pourra rentrer
aller plus loin je vois que c'est ça
les étapes qui nous font de
l'adolescence à l'âge adulte j'espère
qu'ils en ont encore dans l'âge adulte
que je veux dire c'est sûr que je pense
que que ça va plus vite sa phase est
plus précipité les étapes entre
l'adolescence et l'âge adulte mais
j'espère bien continuer après
je pense aussi qu'il suffit de se
remettre en question
faut accepter 100 m
c'est en vue de protéger plus tard 2
tous les adolescentes quand tu seras
duick c'est ce système
cette démarche là cette remise en
question
c'est
je pense que c'est ça qui permet de
rester vivant mouais
par exemple c'est ça qui me fait peur
dans le coup
c'est le fait qu'on s'en remettent plus
en question que on progresse plus
est ce qu'on peut attendre à vie
éviter cet écueil
ouais
[Musique]
à